What if you like, even if on principle,
I agree with Islam?
>> Yeah. How can I get past that when I
know, like it might have been let no
more normalized, but still like There's
people that follow it. It's an innate
like I I I I I do. I do.
>> that's nine, I would never ever do No,
no, no, no, I I do. I do. My friend.
that. Get rid My friend. My friend.
My friend. Don't you love the Sharia?
You love the Sharia. I do not. Why? I'm
not allowed
Everything you own, from your clothes to
your car, to your wife or your husband,
is going to forget you and move on and
be replaced the moment you die. That's
what Allah says,
"Takaathur hatta zurtumul makaabir." You
are busy with the worldly affairs until
you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, Masjid Norway, the one that we
built, is looking to another Masjid
around the area of Norway, subhanallah,
where there's so many Muslims that do
not have somewhere to pray. This Masjid
is only $500,000. And any donation that
you give will go towards your akhirah
because when you enter that grave,
nobody's going to remember you except
Allah subhana wa ta'ala. So, make it
count, brothers and sisters, and donate
towards this Masjid, inshallah. A new
project that's only $500,000. And
believe me, if every single one of us
give 1 pound, 10 pounds, 100 pounds,
1,000 pounds, that's going to be
something you will never regret on Yawm
al-Qiyamah. And everything that you lose
is going to perish and go. But your
deeds on Yawm al-Qiyamah are not.
Donate to the link, inshallah. Let's get
to the video.
What are you guys up to?
We're just here just having a good time.
Going to casino.
Casino? Is Is that allowed in your
religion? I mean, no, not with our
religion. In our religion, it's not
allowed. Gambling is not allowed.
Obviously, murder is not allowed. Six
out of seven marriages are not allowed.
Drinking alcohol is not allowed. Uh the
reason it's not allowed is because these
things No, no, no, no, no, no. You're
not No, no, no, no. No, no, no. You can
No, no, it's I appreciate Thank you, but
No, no, no. This This is your life. This
is This is your Well, it's our country,
but you know, you can do whatever you
like. We don't believe in like you have
to We can't enforce our religion on
other people. Do you get it? My job is
just to explain why we don't do those
things. And if you see like, "You know
what? It makes sense. It doesn't make
sense." Or let me ask more questions.
So, I'm here. So, don't feel offended.
>> do you believe that Sharia law should be
like the the law for England?
>> I would want Sharia law for the whole
world, but I can't say that I can
enforce it. So for instance, if I said
to you, if I said to you, would you want
British lifestyle
for everyone? You say, "Yeah." Yeah. Cuz
you believe you believe that it's good
for everyone.
>> I wouldn't necessarily impose my will on
anyone else. That's what That's what I
said. That's what I said. I would want
it, but I can't impose it. It's the same
with you, right? Yeah. You do want it,
but you can't impose it.
What defines imposing it? For example,
forcing you. If I came and said to you,
"You know what? You're drinking alcohol.
You're We're going to implement the
Sharia law on you, mate." That That
That's That's not allowed in my
religion. I can't impose it on you.
Okay. Uh you have a free will to say yes
or no.
>> Can I ask what this is for? The the
donation thing. Okay, so this is where a
charity. So you see, we also print
He wants to donate. Can you
Yeah, just give me 1 second.
Yeah, so basically we're We're We're
We're a charity. So we print these mats
for people who accept Islam and those
who don't know, so it teaches you how to
pray. So we print these mats. So the
donations go towards this course. It's a
charity. Yeah, I'm I'm a volunteer. So
we do a bit of like We have a
discussions and also fundraise. So
Muslims donate. It's a bit like um
It's like a bit like um zakat, which is
obligatory on every Muslim. Yeah,
exactly. That's why yeah. Yeah, so we do
sometimes come here and encourage people
to donate just for the cause, yeah. Um
so yeah, so that's what I said. So we
can't impose. However, we do share the
idea. So we say Islam has come to
protect your mind, your body, yes, your
lineage, your wealth, yes, and uh
different aspects. So that's the reason
why there's certain punishments for
certain things you do. So for example,
in Islam, we believe sex outside of
marriage
there's harms to it. Do you get it?
Number one, heartbreak, yes, then it can
It can affect you as well. There's a lot
of people who fall in love.
Sure, sure. So
if you were born, right, in some like
Amazon tribe Yes.
Yes.
And then what? would you go to your
hell?
>> No. So we In Islam, we're the only
religion that believes that a Christian,
an atheist, a Jew, agnostic have a
potential of going paradise because we
believe in a God that is just. Why would
he throw someone in the hell?
>> How would they know to not eat pork? No,
that's what No, that's what I'm saying.
So, because they don't know, they cannot
be judged based on what they don't know.
Allah says in the Quran, we do not
destroy nations until we send the
messenger. Unless they are warned, they
know, then you're in trouble. So, for
example, if I explain Islam to you guys
and you're like, "You know what? This is
the true religion." And you're like,
"Well, I don't want to follow cuz I want
to go party, clubbing, and whatever."
That's the thing like we know Islam but
we still eat We still eat pork. No,
exactly. But But do you know Islam to a
level where you're like, "This is the
truth"? No. You know Islam to a level
of, "Oh, I know what halal is. I know
what haram is. Oh, I know they don't
gamble." But not to the level where
you're like, "Okay, I believe this is
the true way."
Correct? Yeah. Good. So, if you do know
and you reject, you're in trouble.
That's if you're If you know deep down
this is the correct path. But if you If
it's not, we believe that these people
would judge on the day of judgment. Now,
going back to gambling, alcohol, sex
outside of marriage, these are things
like I came to Islam 13 years ago. I I
was not a Muslim. I know I look Muslim.
Yeah, but I was not a Muslim. Yeah, I
know I don't know what that looks like,
yeah. Okay. So, so, so the thing is So,
the thing is I used to come clubbing and
partying here. I've done the girls and
the partying and the clubbing and I've
done all of that. I was not a Muslim.
So, when I came to Islam, I came to
Islam because I realized this This
lifestyle is boring. It was getting
boring. The girls were losing respect.
The girls were getting boring. The
partying was getting boring. I didn't do
gambling.
>> Yeah, but if someone offered you Islam
before you went through that phase. Say
that again? If someone offered you Islam
before you went through that phase. Yes.
Would you still be like, "Yeah, yeah, I
want to do this instead of doing that"
or be like, "Yeah, I've done it now.
It's boring."
Are you talking about Islam or you
talking about the lifestyle before it?
What you would have done that before you
went to that lifestyle. Before you went
out partying, drinking. Would I have
Would
Would I come to Islam? If you had done
it, you'd be like, "Okay, now I've done
it now. Okay, good. Yes, yes. So, so,
I'll be honest with you. It's It's with
me I I clocked on a bit early. So, I
could have carried that lifestyle onto
my 30s. I'm 36 years old. So, I could
have carried on. But I clocked on real
early that Come on, there must be a
bigger purpose in life. I I I can't be
just here just to drink, party. Cuz
what's the difference between me and a
cow?
The cow drinks, the cow drinks, And cow
eats, the cow sleeps, the cow cow goes
toilet. So what's the difference between
me and a cow?
He does the exact same thing. I mean,
the cow doesn't go partying. Who
established the no gambling rule?
Because I take it there was no gambling
back back in the Quran, was there?
>> No, no, there is. So gambling goes in
different ways. You get it? Gambling is
not just, for example, going and having
machines. It's betting. So they would do
betting in different ways. So what Islam
says is that it harms your
your wealth. So Islam has come to
protect your wealth. So when you go in
there, it If you think about it when you
go in there, the house always wins.
Yeah.
That that's it. So Unless you count
cards. Unless what?
>> Unless you count cards. I mean, that's a
different thing, but there's people who
have lost their lives. Do you know how
many people jump in front of the trains
because of gambling?
Guys, can I ask a question?
So
what would you say to people that think
they they follow the Quran like to the
word? Yeah. All right. And they think
that justifies them being violent
against non-believers. Yeah. I I would
say I'm I would say I'm that person who
follows the Quran to the word. So you
believe that because we don't believe in
Islam, you should kill us.
Okay. If that's Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I follow this book to the letter.
So why are you killing us right now?
Well, that's that's the point in that,
because the thing is here, I follow this
book. I don't sugarcoat my religion.
When you come and ask me a question,
I'll tell you yeah. I'll tell you
there's I'll tell you I'll tell you
there's a capital punishment in Islam.
I'll tell you like all of this stuff.
I'm not ashamed of it. There's capital
punishment, yes, and we believe that if
somebody, for example, has murdered
somebody
if you lived if if this was a Sharia run
country, they would be executed in uh
Trafalgar Square. Do you think that's
right? Do you think I think I think I
think that works. Why? Because what
happens to pedophiles and murderers in
this country? Go to prison, hot bath,
hot hot tea, hot bed, hot shower. My
friend Yeah, but that's completely
different to us. We're not pedophiles.
We just non-believers.
>> I I never said you are. So the going to
go cuz he's there's multiple questions
being asked to me. So if we could rewind
and go back to the question of One
question. Yeah, yeah. So if we go back
to the disbelievers, nowhere in my faith
tells me to fight you because you're a
disbeliever. Okay, but okay, but okay,
say I grew up, right, in a Christian
family. Yes.
Yeah.
Do you think I deserve really to
like go to hell and all that stuff? No,
no, no, look, that's why I said to you,
if you, a Christian who hasn't heard the
message of Islam, we don't believe you
would go to hell. We believe on the day
of judgment, God will ask you, have you
heard about Islam? You say, "God, I
lived my life. I knew nothing about
Islam." Then God will test you with a
test.
If you pass, you go to heaven. If you
fail, you go to hell. Just to be just
cuz it would be unfair for God to send
you
>> the test be like? Okay, so we believe
the test what we told to us in our in
our faith is that God Almighty will
present himself to you and bring
hellfire. And he will tell you, "I am
your lord and I am telling you to jump
in the hellfire. If you do and trust me,
you will find it to be paradise." Now,
that's a test because you're looking,
visually you can see hellfire, but he's
promising you if you jump in it, you'll
be finding it paradise. So, it's a test
to have trust in God. Okay, but how can
you expect people like us to have that
faith to Good, cuz you know why? Cuz I
had that faith in this life by believing
in him without seeing him.
Okay, but you don't think it's
unreasonable to ask people to believe in
something they don't they don't see? No,
no, no, no, he will show you. So, you
said, "What's your test as a Christian
on the day of judgment?" So, your test
would be that because you're looking at
something that is hellfire. And God's
telling you, "If you have faith in me,
I'm telling you I am God. I'm asking you
to jump in." What that does is it shows
that if you have faith. Now, I went
through that in my life or all let's say
whoever ends up in paradise by being
tested without believing in God. Look, I
felt I don't gamble, I don't drink, I
don't have sex outside of marriage.
There's things I might want to do I
can't do. So, I had that faith in God,
so my reward will be that I've gone
through the
Why for what? What for what?
Oh, wait, for what? Okay, good. So, this
this is where the argument goes back to.
We as Muslims, we don't believe in blind
faith. Right. I can bring you evidence
as to why the Quran is the truth. I can
believe I I prove to you that God
exists. Do you get it? Prove it to me
then. Good. Good. Good. Perfect. You've
got four. You've got four non-believers.
Perfect. Perfect. Okay, non-believers in
God or non-believers in religion?
Can I just say one thing?
>> Yes. I struggle to believe in a religion
where and I'm I'm not even trying to
disrespect the religion in and of
itself.
>> But I've heard a lot Yeah. that Muhammad
Yeah. I'm not sure consummated the
marriage with Aisha
>> At the age of nine. Yes. I just really
like as much as like even if on
principle I agree with Islam
>> Yeah. how can I get past that when I
know and I know you say like back in the
day like it might have been let no more
normalized but still like There's people
that follow the religion.
I I I I
I do. I do.
I would never ever
>> No. No. No. No. I I I I believe I
believe that. Yes. But but let me tell
you there's context behind it. So
there's multiple questions being asked.
Let me dissect one by one. First you
asked about can we fight the
disbelievers because of it because of
them being disbelievers? That's not
true. If that was the case I would be
fighting you now. Okay. So number one my
religion doesn't say to me fight you
guys because you're disbelievers.
There's nowhere in Islam it tells me
that I have to fight the disbelievers
because they're disbelievers. No. Allah
says in the Quran in chapter 60 verse 8
he says um that God does not forbid you
from being just and kind to those who
don't believe based on their faith.
Unless you attack me and kick me out my
house then I have a right to defend
myself.
>> here but I saw that if like if you're
offered the chance to come to Islam
Yeah. and and then you accept it it's
fine. But if you decline and then then
it's allowed to like
do whatever to them. No.
Do Do you mean Do you mean yourself or
do you mean someone who came to Islam
and left? I I saw I saw something I saw
a Muslim saying you go to a civilization
or a place and they accept Islam it's
fine. If it's not then you're allowed to
There's three There's three There's
three options. When a Muslim empires
they conquer lands. Do you know the
Muslim empire? They They They fought the
Romans and the Persians and defeated
them. They gave them three options.
Come and join us be Muslims. What does
that mean? We don't go there and say we
want your oil. We want your gold. We
want your money. We don't want your
wealth.
Yes. We're saying would you come and
join us in faith? They say, "No, thanks.
We're okay, mate. We We just want to
stay as Christians." That's fine. You're
going to pay the tax.
It's a political tax. It's a jizya.
>> So,
okay, now, the tax The tax is like
>> seen that on TikTok. Okay, okay, good,
good, good. So, so, so, so, so
>> [laughter]
>> So, was it Was it me? Yeah, it was you.
Okay,
so Okay, that's good. So, you need to
You need to pay the jizya tax. Why? What
that means is this, that is only for the
fighting men. So, if you guys are
fighting age, which you are, you can
join the army
>> Just about. Well, just about. You guys
will have to pay that one dinar, which
is a gold coin, per year. So, you say to
us, "Listen,
we're okay as a Christian. What's the
tax you want us to pay? One dinar a
year." Now, if you look at the UK,
Yeah.
And I have to pay. I'm I'm I mean, here
are This is your laws. I have to pay or
I can get I can go back to my country.
Yeah? Get back to your country, mate.
Bye-bye. You know what?
No, no, no, no, that's fair. No, that's
That's That's That's fair. No, that's
fair. You know why? Cuz if I'm here,
I'm by your laws, unless you come and
tell me I can't practice my faith, then
I'm getting out of here. If you say,
"Look, practice your faith, mate. We
need you to pay this tax all day, every
day." You know why? Cuz, mate, I pay
tax. A believer is I pay all kinds of
tax, mate. You're going to pay national
insurance, this tax, that tax, road tax.
But, my car got towed cuz I didn't have
tax on it, and it wasn't even my fault,
yeah? Okay. I pay In this country,
you pay so much different tax. If you
earn over 100,000 pounds, you pay 40 or
60 50% of your money to the government.
My friend
My friend My friend My friend My friend,
then you love the sharia. You love the
sharia.
One
dinar a year, all day, every
>> [laughter]
>> Wait a minute. One sec. One sec. One
sec. One sec. What's your name? Angus.
Angus, Angus. Guys, if you think about
it, I love the sharia, mate. One dinar a
year. Thank you very much, mate. All
day, every day, I'll be driving a
Rolls-Royce.
Yes, for for for non-Muslims, but check
out now. If it was discriminatory, it
Why is that as Muslims, me and my wife
have to pay 2.5% of our wealth? Yeah,
but do do Can I ask a question? You do,
but I think this is off topic, yeah?
Yeah.
Oh.
>> [laughter]
>> If this is off topic, this something?
Yes. Do you think that Can you guys come
a little bit closer? Sorry, I'm trying
to stretch. Do you think that your
religion has a propensity for people to
interpret it in a way to cause violence
and
No. The Bible
Good. Okay, good. So, what I would say
is this. Yeah. Because media gets more
attention to Muslims
than non-Muslim attackers, that's why to
you, you make it seem like that. For
example, knife crime happens all the
time. The only time we start panicking
and thinking someone's going to stab me
is when the news start covering it. My
friend, knife crime has been always the
same. People have been stabbed left,
right, center. The news don't cover it,
you don't know. No, no, no, no. That guy
in New Zealand that that shot up that
church.
No, no, no, no. I'm not talking I'm not
I'm not talking about a a a terrorist
motivated, ideologically motivated. I'm
talking about knife crime.
For your jewelry, or etc. I'm saying
well, why does that happen? They say
they're following the Quran to justify
But that's what I'm telling you. The
reason you asking that question is
because the news media have given more
coverage. Do you know Muslims are eight
times more likely to be covered on the
news media? If you going to stab
somebody and you said in the name of in
the name of Jesus, in the name of
whatever, yeah, the pineapple pizza.
It would not be it would not be covered.
How's that expected? If you're a
minority in any place and you're
disproportionately committing a crime.
Who said who said who said that's a
fact? Who said that's the case? No, but
I'm saying if that is the case I'm not
about who said that is the case. Because
what you're saying now is if we're a
minority and disproportionately we are
carrying out all these attacks, you're
correct, but who said that's correct?
Say again? Who said that is the fact
that's happening, that we are a minority
and we're the ones who's doing the
attacks? No, I'm saying theoretically
No, no, no, no, not theoretically. I'm
talking about facts. When it comes to
facts, what you've been told and what is
the reality is different. If you're
saying Muslims are this much of the
population and you guys are carrying out
terrorist attacks every week, I'll say
you're right. But that's not even true.
We get more news coverage because of our
faith. But however, there are Christians
who do mad stuff. There are other faiths
that do mad stuff with different names.
No.
No. That's what I'm saying to you. No,
let me tell you something. If you look
at If you look at Good, but let's look
at facts.
It's not It's not
One second. No, no, no, no. I'm I'm not
saying I'm talking about globally
globally. Let's look at it, yeah? If you
look at top
five or six ideologies, Islam is sixth
on the list. Athe- Christianity is
number one. Atheism is number two.
Number one for what?
For killing For killing innocent Yes,
terrorist attacks. Proportionate to how
many there are in the world. No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. There's
more than There's more than a billion
atheists. No,
no, no, no. Atheists have killed the
most people. Mao Zedong, Stalin,
Mao Zedong nothing. He's What
are you talking about? He's an atheist.
He's an atheist. One second. World War I
started by Muslims? World War II?
Communism Communism is atheism.
Communism goes to the ideology of
Charles Darwin when it talks about
I forgot the word with this the the
superior race. The superior race. No,
no, no, no, superior race. Communism is
just stupid. No, but it it goes back to
atheism.
It Of course it is. No, it isn't.
>> it is. No, it isn't. No, no, no, no, no.
Communism
Communism doesn't I'm not saying I'm
saying communists don't even let you to
No Christians and Jews or Muslims can
exist in a communist state. All
religions the opium of the masses.
Exactly. Do you see Do you see what he
said? And they write that in Marx Marx
they write about this book. Do you get
it? So, what I'm saying is the
following. If you look at statistics,
who have killed more innocent people?
The West. No, but I'm saying I'm saying
most people in the West are saying your
religion and what the Well, well, one
second. When they When they went to Iraq
and When they went to Iraq, George Bush
and Tony Blair, Yeah, yeah, yeah. George
Bush, he's he's said
>> agree with that. I don't No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no. One second. Just I
can say the same thing I don't agree
with those terrorists doing those
attacks. Yeah, good. So, what I'm saying
is this though. When they went to Iraq
When they went to Iraq and Afghanistan,
yeah? My friend, apparently 9/11 was
done by Muslims. They were apparently
Saudi. I think it's a conspiracy, boy.
>> [laughter]
>> We know We know We know who done it. We
know who done it. I think it was an
inside job. We know who done it. Mossad.
Yeah? Yes, Mossad.
It's clear, my friend. There were three
Jews Zionist Jews who Who caught in a
van laughing when the attacks happened?
And who were they connected they were
Mossad agents? What were they doing
there and why were they looking and
laughing? I wonder what. Who attacked
the USS Liberty? Who attacked the USS
Liberty?
Mossad. Epstein Island, pedophile
island. Mossad.
My friend, of course he was.
Of course he was. Her her dad, Robert
Maxwell, bro, when he died he was buried
he was buried in in in Jerusalem. Yes,
by Mossad
Religion is the worst problem. No.
By Jewish people? Not really. Zionist
Zionism Zionism Look look
No no no.
What about atheists? Atheists Atheists
are second. Christianity is the worst
that they killed most amount of people.
Then there's atheists. Now, Nagasaki and
Hiroshima, who dropped those bombs?
Muslims.
And by the way, the war was over.
Japanese was ready to surrender. They
said, "Nope, we're going to drop these
bombs on innocent people."
No no no, they did. After Pearl Harbor
Pearl Harbor No, after Pearl Harbor
So that So that
So that So that There was Listen.
There was this There was There was a
couple of crackhead Japanese people. So
so we said, "You know what? We're going
to drop Hiroshima and Nagasaki
and kill innocent people." Now, in in
our religion, if you notice, what's
happening in Gaza?
They are using texts from the Bible. In
the Bible it clearly says, "Go to
Amalekite, kill men, women, children,
babies, and donkeys, yeah?" Okay,
firstly, I don't know what the donkey
done.
Yeah. I've seen the Torah. It says some
Good. Now. No no. There is
There is There is There is There is
There is not a single place in the Quran
that tells us to kill innocent people,
period. There's not a single scripture
in the Quran.
Good.
Okay, good. So what I'm saying is
just the same way where you have nutters
like Mao Zedong and Stalin, just you
have the guy who done the New Zealand
attack when he went to a mosque and
start killing people. There's crazy
people everywhere. Hello, we have some,
too. What I'm saying is this, though.
When you come and make it seem as if we
are the only one we have this problem.
No, we don't. Because if you look at 1
million people killed in Iraq for oil,
half a million Afghanistan
>> No, we're not saying Islam's the main
reason. Good. Let me tell you what the
reason is. You know what it is? No, no,
you know what activates it? When we go
into their lands and bomb their men,
women, and children. And this MI5, you
know who talks about this? You Look, US
officers, MI5, FBI agents, they've said
clearly the reason why these guys are
motivated is because we go to
Afghanistan, drop a bomb, kill innocent
men, women, and children. He looks and
says, "You know what? Imagine we come to
Look, you Look, like today you ask me
questions. Hear me out. Hear me out. You
ask questions about certain Muslims that
do terrible stuff. And it gets you
angry. It gets me angry. Who are you to
come to my country when I'm walking with
my family and you live and blow yourself
up or stab people? Do you not want to
take revenge? Of course you do. Come on,
it's a natural inclination.
>> Yeah, but does that not mean you stoop
down to their level if you take
>> No, but a natural inclination is what?
Why are they doing this? And you and I
have every right to say, "When I'm
walking down the road with my family
member, a far right can come and say,
'Muslim terrorist. Kill him.'"
Guess what the Muslim does? Same crap.
Kuffar. Family. Now, the point is this
though, how do you think most of them
are politically orientated? Okay?
Terrorism is what? Doing acts of
violence for political gains. Now, these
people are saying, "You're coming to my
country, bombing the crap out of my
country, and then when I'm out of
nothing to live for, I have to swim to
your country to make a living." And then
so ideology is not even connected to
Islam. Yes, some idiots will shout
"Allahu Akbar." What the hell has that
got to do with anything? Why are you
shouting God is great?
>> think Al-Qaeda is not really like No,
no, no. I I
I can No, I would say they are Muslims.
They are terrible Muslims. Terrible.
ISIS 100%.
>> interpreting it wrong. No, yes. And not
only that, they kill more Muslims than
they do the believers. You know ISIS,
for some odd reason they don't follow
any rockets to Israel.
For some odd reason. What? Do you think
they're like an Israel or who?
Mossad. I do not know.
>> [laughter]
>> You did not
You did not You did brush over the fact
that Aisha was not Oh, yeah, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no. We can come to that.
No, I I'm I'm We ask him multiple
questions, man. Come on. What do you
want to ask him?
Now, come back to the Prophet's marriage
to Aisha. Do you want to go to that
first or prove God first?
>> No, I want Aisha.
So to me So to me, the question I will
ask you is the following. We believe the
Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him,
made a marital contract at the age of
six and waited for her to become an
adult at the age of nine. Now,
that's just nuts to me.
Listen, let's deal with this
intellectually, not emotionally. Now, my
question is the following. I believe the
Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him, his
wife, his first wife, some say he he she
was 15 years older than him. So, he was
a 25-year-old man and she was 40.
Yeah, Khadija was his first wife was
Khadija. Yes? So, deep that says she's
nine, is it? If I'm wrong, No, no, no,
no, I'm telling you she's nine. I'm not
going to cut my religion. I'm not going
to come and say she was 18. No, she was
not 18, she was nine. Now, I'm saying
this, we need to look at who the Prophet
Muhammad is. He had a wife who was 15
years older than him and he was 25 years
old. Now, if a man has those kind of
inclinations in a sit in a country in a
place that he lived, women were like
after a camel. It was the men, camel,
and then the women. No, no, that's how
it was. That's how it was. They
mistreated women. So much so, do you
know they used to bury girls alive?
I saw in Afghanistan a woman got stoned
to death. You see to be stoned to death.
I teach and girls Taekwondo in
Afghanistan. Cuz they're they're not
allowed to follow their I would I would
say that might be propaganda. They do
they do some they do some mad stuff
there. Okay. Now, the Prophet's first
No, because that one for for teaching
Taekwondo, nah. If you said to me a
crime of adultery, I would say maybe
yeah.
There is nowhere in Islam that tells you
you can
There is nowhere in Islam that says that
if a woman teaches sports you can kill
Oh.
But even then, to kill someone cuz he
teaches Taekwondo, I I don't believe in
that. I will I will write to see facts.
I I have to Look, he's going to think
that I'm running away from it. Good.
Now, how The fact that he had sex
I can't get past. You need to get me
past that right now. I'm trying to and
I'm getting stopped. Okay, now, That's
traffic lights. Yeah, okay. So, what I'm
saying is
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, listen. Now, so what I'm saying is
the Prophet's first wife was 15 years
older than him. So, now, we need to look
at the motivation. A pedophile is what?
Somebody who has what? Sex with an
underage girl.
>> No, attraction to minors.
Yeah, but what defines a minor?
>> Minor, good. Thank you very much. The
question is this, what defines a child,
what defines a teenager, what defines an
adult? Now, because
>> but bro, like are you seriously saying a
9-year-old, like come on, like I I'll
repeat again, did I anywhere say that?
No, but if Muhammad do it and he's he's
perfect, he does everything right.
>> you're asking, but you're not listening.
You're you're listening to reply, not
listening to hear me.
>> No, but you follow him by the letter of
the law.
You you you follow you follow it by the
letter of the law.
>> [laughter]
>> friends are complaining. They say they
say you listen to reply, not listen to
learn. Hear me out. No, but you follow
his actions to the T and that is his
action.
>> I'm
explaining to you, you're cutting me as
I'm explaining. Yes, it's okay, you need
to listen. You need to I don't I don't
want to cook. Listen to understand.
>> Yeah, I smell it.
>> Now, what I'm saying is this, the
prophet peace be upon him, if he had
those inclinations, a if he had those
inclinations, number one, we're saying
you cannot treat a 9-year-old today to
the 9-year-old to 1,400 years ago,
period. Because let me tell you
something.
Of my friend, the difference, 1,400
years number one, the climate number
two, the life expectancy number three,
you have got so much difference. You're
looking at a 9-year-old today. I would
never ever, even in this country, Islam
doesn't tell me that we have to marry a
9-year-old. It says that a woman becomes
an adult. Now, the question I'm asking
you is the following, if the Prophet
Muhammad had an inclination to minors,
why did he wait three years we believe
she became a adult. You're saying a
9-year-old cannot be an adult and I'm
saying to you, is it categorically or
consequentially wrong?
>> do you hear how that sounds? That almost
sounds like you're waiting till she's
legal, like that's like that's just
>> do you not do that here? Do you not wait
for a girl to be 16 for it to be legal?
>> no, but if you're like a 25-year-old
bloke and you're like, oh, she's 17 now,
so I'm going to wait I'm going to Is
that legal or illegal? One second, if a
25-year-old man or a 30-year-old man or
a 40-year-old man
>> It's it's just weird.
>> My friend,
>> my friend, I'm talking about the law of
UK. Law of the UK says if a 35 or a
40-year-old man has intimacy with a
16-year-old girl, is it legal or
illegal? No, but No, but it's not the
>> Is it legal or illegal, my friend? Wait,
if she If he has a 9-year-old No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, but
what One second. No, no. I'm annoyed.
You're not even having a period. No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
My friend, my friend, my friend, my
friend, my friend, my friend, my friend.
Is it legal or illegal if a 40-year-old
man has intimacy with a 16-year-old
today?
>> it's illegal. I think it has to be 18.
If you're above 18, it has to You get
You I think you have to get married at
18. 16, you can have sex. That's why we
have the pandemic of teenage pregnancy
in the UK. The point I'm saying is this,
we believe the Prophet Muhammad, his
wives were 60 years old, 40 years old,
45 years old. His only wife that was
that young, and I say we say that she
became an adult at the age of nine. Now,
you need to come and prove to me how a
9-year-old today is the same as a
9-year-old tomorrow that day. How is it
different? How is a 9-year-old No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. I'm the
non-believer. You're the one that's
telling me your religion is correct. You
have to prove it to me.
>> have Okay. You You have to You have to
prove to me, categorically or
constructively
>> to believe your religion? I don't I
don't I don't want to be my religion.
You're asking me a question. I'm saying
you have to bring evidence, put emotions
aside, that a 9-year-old today is the
same 9-year-old back then. No, no, okay,
but how do you know it's not? Good.
Perfect. Let me tell you why. I told
you, for example, in England In England,
if you read uh
I've forgot his name. British common
law, okay?
And girls were betrothed at the age of
seven in this country. What I'm saying
is this, you're claiming that for 14
years in UK, your great-grandfathers
were pedophiles.
Do you know Do you know how old your
great-grandfather would have get married
and your great-grandmother?
I don't know, but Oh, my friend, 10, 11,
12, 13. And they were wrong. They were
committing
>> no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, one second.
Oh, don't disrespect your grandfather.
Come on. My friend. Well, if he's
a 9-year-old, I'm not going No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, you You know
what it's called? It's called the
fallacy of presentism. Because you live
in today's society and you look at a
9-year-old, you are judging that
9-year-old to your great-grandfathers.
I'm saying guys as young as 11, 12 were
at war. They were providing for their
family. While we play PlayStation or
Call of Duty, they were working in the
in the But isn't the age gap what a
9-year-old would be like the equivalent
of a 16, 17, 18-year-old? Perfect. Thank
you.
You need to prove how. You know why? No,
no, no, no, no, no, no. How?
But but how? Because I'm saying to you,
we have many examples. Look, look. But
what are you basing it off of? That they
One second.
There was a king There was a king There
was a king here who married a I think a
six or seven-year-old for France. But
one second.
No, no, but
one second. No, no, but I'm saying I
don't believe they were marrying minors.
They were marrying
They adults that became adults. You're
claiming a 9-year-old is a child, and
I'm saying what do you define as a
child? Well, but let's say let's say
there weren't there weren't those laws
then. They were adults. I'm saying to
categorically, they were adults. Today,
Yes. would you think it's okay if you
married a 9-year-old today? I There's
nowhere in my religion that tells me
that I need to marry a 9-year-old. But
what I'm saying is if you did, if you
did, you think it'd be okay? No, cuz no.
Of course not. Because my religion
Because my religion
No, they don't. No, they don't. But I
have My friend, look. The issue The
issue
My friend, in investigative journalism,
most pedophiles are white middle-aged
men. That If anything, if anything, if
anything, if anything is a white man's
problem, not our problem.
It [laughter] feels like a cop-out to
say that. It feels like It feels like a
cop-out to tell you that 99% of
pedophiles are white middle-aged men.
Wait, depends where you are. It depends
where you are. Sorry. 99.9.
Come on, let's be real. Let's be real.
Come on, if you're in India, it's not
going to be 99% white No, no, no, no,
no. I'm I'm talking about Europe, and
I'm talking about the West. I'm not
talking about India. India's a different
story. Exactly. Good. So, what I'm
saying is the issue of pedophilia, this
problem is not our problem. Because we
believe that a woman has to be mentally,
physically, and sexually ready. Which
means what? What's the legal age in the
UK? But then who's to define that?
Good. That's my problem. It's
subjective. What's the legal age in the
UK? 16. What's the legal age in France?
I don't I'm not sure. 15. What's the
legal age in America?
12, 13, 14. 250,000 girls have been
married under age.
Check check it out.
Check check it out in states. This is
what I'm saying. This is why it's so
important. 12, 13, 14. Check
Check check check check.
No, no, no, no, no.
Yes, check it. There's 25-year-old
married a 12-year-old a 12-year-old.
No, check. No, check my friend. No,
there you go. Look, I'll show you now.
I'll show you now.
One second. No, watch this. Watch this.
One second.
Check this. I'll show you now.
Girls married under age
in America.
in America
No, no. I speak facts.
I don't do propaganda.
Okay.
Yes.
No, no, no, no.
We're going to see
I want to see the same volume when I put
it up. Yeah? Just make sure your volume
doesn't go down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Just make sure your
volume stays the same. Yes, yes. Let's
just see now. Let's just see that, man.
Watch this.
Watch this now.
No, no, no. America, man.
America
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
The United States of America, my friend.
One second.
No, no, no. Let me have it.
One second, one second. Slow down.
It's just loading.
>> 9-year-old girl. It's the Daily Mail,
not my friend. You're literally saying
that shacking a 9-year-old girl is
mental, right? I didn't even want to say
that. One second.
No, one second.
Independent, it's not owned by Muslims.
Yeah, and even before that, I don't
agree with that. Habibi, brother,
brothers, brothers, brothers, brothers,
brothers, brothers, brothers, I'm here.
What can we do? Even if that wasn't your
original point, even if that is right,
that wasn't your original point. My
original point is what?
>> More than 200,000 children How could
200,000 girls get married in the US This
is legally, not illegally. How big's the
population? How big's the population?
>> is 300 and something million. Yes.
250,000
girls When were they married?
>> I don't believe there is a single Muslim
country that has been studied. Look,
read it. You read it for yourself. Look,
it's the Guardian as well. Don't trust
the Guardian.
>> No, it's not. It's independent. The
Guardian It's not Guardian. The Daily
Mail is independent.
>> It's It's the independent, yes.
Okay, more than 200,000 children were
married in the US over the past 15
years, new figures have revealed. Three
10-year-old girls
Three 10-year-old girls and an
11-year-old boy were among the youngest
wed. Under legal loopholes, which allow
loopholes It's accepted in your
religion. Legal loopholes. Yes, okay.
No, it's not.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
nowhere in Islam it says you should
marry a 9-year-old.
It says when she becomes an adult He's
He's He's like the perfect person. The
Prophet Muhammad The Prophet Muhammad
married an adult at the age of nine. We
are taught to marry an adult. The
16-year-old today is the same as an
adult back then. Now, let's carry on.
The minimum
The minimum The minimum It's It's You
can disagree. You have to bring
evidence. The minimum age of marriage
across most of the US Look, is 18. Most
of US states is 18. But, every state has
exemptions such as parental consent or
pregnancy, which allow younger children
to tie the knot. In May,
the high-profile Republican governor of
New Jersey declined to sign into law a
measure that would have made And he is a
pedo.
I'm not saying he is. I'm saying to you
No, I'm saying he is.
No, I
No, I I disagree I'm with you. I'm with
you. I'm saying
this issue of Peter Filer is your
problem, not our problem.
>> But it's our problem. It's
It is a Western problem.
Of course. Of course.
Of course. I'm saying it is a Western's
problem. It's not a Muslim problem.
No. No. No. No. It's It's It's a It's a
global problem that we should all solve.
However, where it grows is the West
Europe. They go to Now they go to Africa
by the by middle aged men. There's more
child marriages in Europe than there is
in
>> No. Not marriages. I'm talking about
pedophilia. Raping little girls. It is
by middle aged men.
No. No. No. Marriage or not marriage.
What I'm saying is pedophilia pedophilia
[music]
most pedo If I write on Google
pedophiles, you will see people who look
more like Tommy Robinson than me.
Okay, but that's a pretty common That's
a baseless How's that baseless? How's
that baseless? I'm telling you what they
look like. How can a Google search
define the whole picture of something?
>> No. If I write Look. If I write If I
write grooming gangs, it's mostly going
to be Asians.
That's what's going to come up.
It's in Saudi Arabia, too.
I would like to read that. Who's it
Where's it from? I've got ChatGPT. So I
don't know. Okay. I'll check. I'll check
that. I'd like to read it. To me it's
this My My [laughter] My My point My
point is this.
My My My point My point is
No. No. No. No.
What I'm What I'm
What I'm just saying What I'm just
saying
My habit My problem is this. I'm saying
nowhere in our religion does it tell us
to marry minors. What it tells us is
that a girl becomes an adult in
different ages. It can be 16. It can be
17. It can be 18. However, to your world
view, what you're saying to me, this
issue of pedophilia, it arises amongst
Westerners, not Muslims.
Based on what? Based on Based on what?
Based on statistics. If you go and look
at who the main culprits of pedophilia
Are you really telling me the statistics
in like Afghanistan are going to be
reflective of how actually
>> No. No. No. No.
Of course.
Good luck.
I accept that. And I'm saying yes.
I follow his actions. I'll tell you how
I follow his actions.
No. No, no.
What What What
What he done What he done was marry an
adult. What I do is the following. If I
have an 18-year-old son and he's like,
"I want to marry a girl." I'll say, "How
old is she?" She's 14. I'll say, "Sorry,
we have to wait for her to become an
adult." Just like the prophet waited for
Aisha to become an adult. We're going to
use the same principle. When she's 16,
you can marry her. Do you get it?
Yeah.
100%. No, if it's No, if it's not, then
my argument is the following. Can you
prove to me categorically that a
9-year-old and it was Hear me out. Hear
me out. It's a It's an intellectual It's
a No, it's not. It's an intellectual
argument. Can you prove to me a
categorically or consequentially a
9-year-old at any era is the same as
9-year-old today?
That's what I'm saying. You're promoting
your religion. I am an adult.
And And I'm telling you
yes, because you're saying 9-year-old is
wrong at all ages, right? Any era you
lived in. Okay, you have to bring
evidence. Because you made a claim.
Completely, bro. Bro, I have an Look
Look, my friend. I have I have three
daughters. A 9-year-old, a 4-year-old,
and a 2-year-old. My daughter,
9-year-old, are you She's so far from
marriage. My friend, she's playing
Minecraft. I cannot treat her the same
as Aisha and other people.
Whose life? How do you know that back in
the day that was true? Of course.
My friend, my friend. My friend, there
were kings in in Britain, in France, in
the West, around the world. Your
great-grandfathers you called
pedophiles. My friend, no, they're not
pedophiles.
My friend, they lived in the era where
survival My friend, they didn't have
Tesco around the corner to buy food.
No, I look No one had to tell me I don't
know.
I just don't know. If you lived
300 years ago, where you could die by
the age of 25, that's what your life
expectancy
and you had to survive because there are
other tribes coming to kill you, you
would have probably five wives.
No, it's even evolutionary. Look, no,
I'm not saying nine. I'm saying the
times that you lived in, you didn't have
Tesco around the corner to have a ham
sandwich. My friend, you had to hunt
food.
>> Okay. So, what I'm saying is this,
homie, hear me out. So, your
great-grandfathers that you call
pedophiles were not pedophiles. I'm
trying to respect your grandfather. He
was a man who lived in an era where his
life expectancy was 25-30 and he would
in that era have to marry, survive, have
a community he can fight against. So,
say theoretically, in a theoretical
world, Aisha is two.
Do you think No, it's not allowed.
It's not allowed.
You know why? Because
Look, 1 million years ago Perfect,
perfect. A two-year-old was a
20-year-old. Good, perfect. No, it can't
be. Come on. Come on. From the ages of
zero to about I would say anywhere from
six, seven, you are dealing with a
child, okay? Yes. No, let's be honest.
Yes, okay. Six, seven, yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay. So, anyway, so what I'm saying is
this here, you cannot come and say a
nine-year-old, you had Look, you know in
the Industrial Revolution, here in
Britain, this is where teenager, you
know the teenager concept came through.
You know how old was your probably your
dad's dad when he was working in the in
those mines, yes? Have you seen a video
of this young boy? Have you seen a video
of a young boy carrying a ladder? He
looks flipping Have you seen it? He
looks flipping. How old does he look?
About five, he's cool. He's cool.
He's cool.
Do you see what I'm saying?
>> Do you think a nine-year-old back then
is the equivalent to a 60-year-old? I
said to you, yes. See, that's why we
That's why we say that.
Okay, good. I say it's 13 or 14 or 15.
No, no, no. Re- re- re- regardless, the
point Regardless, do we agree that we're
talking about 1400 year difference? Do
we agree that it was a whole different
climate? Do we agree it was a whole
different era?
We have no right to judge your
great-grandparents or any of them. I'm
judging my great-grandparents. I can't.
You know why?
My friend, my friend, there's even
studies that show in really hot climates
girls mature faster. This Look, this is
science.
Look, look, look.
Let's Let's see if these scientists are
pedos.
Let's see if they're Okay, you're going
to call them science pedos now. Watch.
No, me. That might be proof. But are you
seriously telling me there's a there's a
sample study of thousands of people?
No, no, we know that.
Can I just make this one point? One last
point?
No, no, no.
I appreciate it. Tell him I said happy
birthday.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, see, this is chat GPT, but I can
go to it. If you don't take it, okay.
Okay.
I'll go to a study as well. It says
research suggests that girls in hotter,
particularly tropical climates may
experience faster and earlier puberty
compared to those in colder regions.
Have you been to Saudi? I just came back
a week ago. My friend, do you know how
hot it is there? Please.
My friend, I'm just telling you girls
mature What, so their brain matures
faster in the sun?
>> I never I never said that. I said they
biologically mature faster.
My friend, have you have you I don't
know if you guys listen to Have you guys
ever listened to Akon?
Akon, Akon, long time ago.
No, a k o n, Akon. He's a old rapper.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. But then he's
got another track. He's got another
track called Put the Blame on Me. He was
in a nightclub, which was for
18-year-olds, and he had intimacy with a
girl who was 12 or 13, and he said she
had full-blown womanly features. And he
had a bloke going. Spoke that going. I
don't blame him.
He's a pedo.
My friend, my friend, he was in a club
with a girl who was 13 years old.
I can't Let me finish my sentence. Then
you can call him a pedo. It It was a
pedo. My great-grandfather pedo. A pedo.
You pedo. It was a pedo.
>> [laughter]
>> You pedo. You pedo. Okay. What I'm
trying to say is
What is it? He was in a club and came
across a girl, took her back home. She
is a full If you look at her, you see
You say this woman is 27 years old. She
was 13 or 14. The point is what? Even
though it's illegal, I'm not saying it's
right.
>> Did he know? No, he didn't know. That's
what Muhammad knew when he married his
wife. I'm saying yes, that she was an
adult. That's why he waited.
Yes.
No, he married an adult. He married an
adult.
He married He married an adult. He
married an adult. We believe he did not
marry a child. He married an adult. And
you can't bring me evidence that to the
contrary.
Mate, that's just baffling to me. Mate,
I can I can prove God exists in 2
minutes. Okay.
I I respect your opinions. But it's not
about opinions.
I don't I don't do opinions and
emotions. I do with facts. I don't agree
with you, but fair play. I
I respect your knowledge and what
Everything you own, from your clothes to
your car, to your wife or your husband,
is going to forget you and move on and
be replaced the moment you die. That's
what Allah says,
You are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, Masjid Norway, the one that we
built, is looking to another masjid
around the area of Norway subhanallah
where there's so many Muslims that do
not have somewhere to pray. This masjid
is only $500,000. And any donation that
you give will go towards your akhirah
because when you enter that grave,
nobody's going to remember you except
Allah subhanallah wa ta'ala. So, make it
count, brothers and sisters, and donate
towards this masjid inshallah. A new
project that's only $500,000. And
believe me, if every single one of us
give £1, £10, £100, £1,000, that's going
to be something you will never regret on
your Mayamma and everything that you
lose is going to perish and go. But your
deeds on your Mayamma are not.
Donate to the link inshallah. Let's get
to the video.